Two months after the gut detox, which helped me a lot, I started herxine and still continues
although doing copycatamins in sauna, I need something to detox or whatever causes this
is there a supplement to help besides charcoal.
So you have to really define what herxine is.
So you might not be herxine having true herxiber reaction.
You might actually be having some food sensitivity reaction to something you're eating.
So just because you're having symptoms of a herx reaction, it could actually be an immune
stimulation with an autoimmune, so getting some other testing might be valuable.
So if you have a local practitioner that will do a Cyrex test, either a Cyrex 10, which
will test the food sensitivities or a Cyrex 7 and 5 and 7x, which will test for antibodies.
So understand, just because you have cancer, it doesn't mean you don't have other things
going on.
You could have an autoimmune issue and you're doing immune stimulation to kill your cancer.
Well, immune stimulation can kind of spark an autoimmune reaction, which then you got
a way out.
I'm trying to kill my cancer, while I get up to deal with this autoimmune issue, I kind
of put that on the back burner.
But if you're in remission, then it might be good.
This is why we talked about pulsing your supplements, going a week off, your supplements and see
it, it decreases that reaction, because that could be an autoimmune reaction, your immune
system is being stimulated, and you will kill that with your antibodies against first,
which if you have self antibodies, it's going to affect your thyroid if you have Hashimoto's
or something else.
So, I'll do some further investigation.
I'm not a big fan of using symptoms to just say this is a Herk's reaction, because so
often it could be something else.